tours a ici mygale on attend votre feu
vert autorisations accordées
3 2 1
je peux vous aider
en passant je j'ai aperçu la pancarte
bien amazing amazing grace
vous me semble être déjà en est c'est ce
que vous faites comme travail
je vais dans l'informatique aux
ordinateurs oui
d'où est ce que vous venez exactement
karachi là où il y a les talibans ma
femme
et ma fille adolescente ont été tués par
un missile
c'est l'anniversaire de qui a tiré le
missile
pas drôle appartenant à la cia
[Musique]
impact dans dix secondes 2 1 voulez vous
que je dise à fait le femmes et à votre
l'office qui vous êtes vraiment voulez
quoi
vous voulez des aveux pas du tout non
[Musique]
les coupables ne devrait pas être
épargné savez-vous quelle quantité
d'explosifs il ya dans ma manette
laissez les vivre descendez moi le
souvenir
[Musique]